em maio de 2012
eu me juntei a 17 tripulantes de sete
nacionalidades numa expedição atrás dos
resíduos do tsunami japonês
ali não sei no pacífico rodeada de água
ea muito muitas milhas de distância de
qualquer terra firme
eu me sentia isolada apesar de não
parecer ali eu aprendi que no mundo
existem cinco zona de confluência da
maré
são duas no pacífico do atlântico e uma
no índico era exatamente para esses dias
que essa mancha de rede estava se
aproximando
elas são basicamente os ralos do mundo
então é pra lá que todos aqueles
resíduos que a gente de alguma maneira
joga nas correntes d'água se com o
centro o trajeto principal da nossa
expedição passava pela maior dessas
zonas
o giro do pacífico norte é o maior de
todos foi o primeiro a ser descoberto
é um espaço entre o japão eo havaí que
abriga a maior mancha de lixo do planeta
ela é calculada como duas vezes o
tamanho do estado do texas
um pouquinho menor do que o nordeste
brasileiro que acontece nessas zonas é
um acúmulo de fragmentos na maioria das
vezes plásticos e por incrível que
pareça muita gente ouve dizer sobre
ilhas de lixo mas elas não são ilhas não
são partículas sólidas na verdade se
fossem seria muito mais fácil a gente
tentar resolver
eles são pequenos fragmentos que a gente
chama de sopa de microplásticos lá em
existe uma abundância enorme no mercado
já existia na verdade uma abundância
enorme no mercado de produtos contendo
esses micro plásticos esfoliantes pasta
de dente sabonetes é o mesmo que é
bastante ignorante sobre o tema
depois que voltei guardei um restinho
desfolhante na minha gaveta que está lá
e não sai até hoje
aquele impacto pra mim foi muito grande
e eu consegui perceber que naquele
oceano palestino profundo guardava
debaixo da superfície uma realidade dos
resultados do que a gente fazia muito
distante dali a maioria dos plásticos
vem do petróleo e é feita para durar
às vezes milhares de anos mas quando
eles entram em contato com a água eles
sofrem ação do vento das radiações
solares e das correntes e se fragmentam
esses pedacinhos bem pequenininhos
menores do que um grão de arroz
uma vez na água esses grandes e os
pequenos absorvem os poluentes e aí fica
muito fácil para eles se tornarem
alimento para os organismos filtradores
e saíamos o plantão e é a base da cadeia
alimentar aquática do zooplâncton pro
nosso prato deve levar alguns meses em
comparação existem mais microplásticos
nos oceanos do que estrelas na nossa
galáxia
nossa expedição durou cerca de seis
semanas ea gente estou plástico a cada
três minutos e meio de todas as amostras
diárias 73% deram positivo para
fragmentos plásticos
essa transferência de impacto tem sido
notada também em outras fontes de água
então a água de torneira vem sendo
testado e as águas engarrafadas
recentemente uma pesquisa a gente
percebeu que das 159 amostras retiradas
em cinco continentes 93% deram positivas
para microfibras plásticos um casaco de
poliéster só tem em média um milhão de
fibras ao ser lavado
aí tem desafios que a gente nem imagina
de lá pra cá a gente avançou bastante em
comprovar os fatos e mergulhar muito nas
na origem dessas microfibras e dessas
partículas mas a verdade é que a gente
tem feito bem pouco para solucionar o
problema de uma forma escalável
o que acontece é que a gente válida
todos os dias um modelo economicamente
linear de produção e consumo que isso
quer dizer
quer dizer que a gente retira os
recursos da natureza que a gente
transforma eles consomem e joga fora
só que fora não existe
tudo que a gente uma vez descarta vai
ser transferido ou
para o ar para terra ou para a água
esse modelo totalmente fadado ao
fracasso daqui até 2050 a população
mundial vai gerar 70% a mais de resíduos
do que a gente gera hoje aonde vai parar
esse lixo
a transformação para uma economia mais
circular passa pela reutilização dos
recursos de forma mais contínua e pelo
redesenho dos produtos e dos serviços de
uma forma a durar mais
o lixo um erro de design na natureza
esse conceito não existe
a florada de uma cerejeira é alimento
para o solo das próximas gerações
não sei se vocês já sabem disso mas nos
últimos 25 anos os países ricos mandavam
seus resíduos para os países mais pobres
basicamente os países asiáticos que
tinham muito pouca capacidade de
absorver aquele material
a china por exemplo com tinha 45 por
cento dessas importações
a maior parte do plástico global que não
servia mais para alguns países ricos era
enviado para lá no começo deste ano a
china se cansou e falou não quer mais
receber esses materiais 24 tipos de
resíduos foram banidos de serem enviados
causando uma comoção global essa decisão
afetou demais essas nações e fez com que
eles começassem a procurar outros
lugares para enviar seus materiais
na verdade era muito mais barato enviar
para outro país do que tentar tratar
aquilo no local
bom você deve imaginar o caos que
começou a acontecer é uma oportunidade
enorme na minha visão para países como
estados unidos e alguns da europa e
pensar em um modelo que eles apoiaram
linear e que começou há muito tempo
atrás onde eles construíram a sua
infraestrutura com a certeza ea garantia
de que eles poderiam delegar o lixo
deles pra outro lugar
aí vem uma boa oportunidade de a gente
rever esse conceito da reciclagem
os esforços com reciclagem não têm sido
suficientes
a verdade é que aqui pro brasil pra
maioria dos materiais
o valor que a gente tem o material
reciclado não supera o custo do processo
de reciclagem
um agravante a isso a gente no brasil
tem de 600 a 1 milhão de catadores de
materiais
lá viu que trabalham para fazer essa
porcentagem bem pequena que a gente tem
existe um arquivo também quando a gente
fala sobre reciclável reciclado o que é
reciclável 90% do que a gente coloca no
mercado
quer dizer que tem capacidade para tal
capacidade técnica para tal mas o que
está sendo reciclado que no brasil entre
5 e 3% é muito diferente disso
a verdade é que esses materiais têm uma
complexidade muito maior
a gente precisa de concentração a gente
precisa de limpeza eles precisam estar
no lugar certo na hora certa existe um
universo de complexidades e de variáveis
e custo logístico enfim que a gente não
percebe no momento em que a gente faz
aquele descarte
agora eu não sou um ativista contra o
plástico proplástico é um material
fantástico ele trouxe diversos avanços
para a saúde da sociedade e para a nossa
vida comum e também avanços ambientais
mas a verdade é que a gente tem que sim
questionar alguns usos
quando eu dou exemplo para vocês de que
se eu entro numa cozinha ea torneira
está vazando eu tenho duas opções ou
pego um balde para tirar aquela água
eu tento para a torneira de vazar a
reciclagem que a gente utiliza hoje é a
questão do balde
a gente vai tirar a água os estragos vão
ser diminuir mas o que a gente tem que
fazer é atacar pela fonte
quando a gente fala sobre embalagens de
uso único a gente está pensando na fonte
essa fonte que a gente precisa atacar
então hoje antes de vir pra cá com vocês
eu fui almoçar no restaurante e pedisse
ao e eles me deram e sozinho aqui
o curioso é que aqui tem mais embalagem
do produto
será que essa é a forma certa gente
entregava sal para alguém da gente saiu
da nossa comida com os orgânicos
acontece uma coisa curiosa também né as
pessoas têm a idéia de falar vou
consumir orgânico e chega lá e falar
poxa mas ele tá todo em volta de redinha
c e roupinhas e reflete bandeirinhas e
tal
a verdade é que aqui no brasil produto
certificado orgânico ele precisa sim ser
embalados do começo até o fim da cadeia
será que não tem uma forma diferente da
gente fazer isso
era da praticidade de descartabilidade a
gente chegou ao absurdo de embalar
banana mexerica e até coco outro dia eu
vi o coco embalado coco com canudinho
balado lindo lá puxa vida
eu sou o terror dos supermercados nesta
devem imaginar das 8 milhões de
toneladas de plástico vão parar nos
oceanos todos os anos
metade é usada somente uma vez uma vez
já tem pararam pra pensar na jornada
dessas embalagens né o quanto segundo
ela fica na sua mão até você jogar lá
fora o papel de bala a própria garrafa
[Música]
mas essa aplicação não é só no produto
né a lógica muitas vezes também tem sido
aplicada de uma maneira errada
eu recentemente fui visitar um
supermercado que vende a granel
leterme o potinho de casa e falei com
atendente que me disse que eu não
poderia utilizar o meu porte levado de
casa
ok aí ele me falou que os portes
descartáveis já tinham sido levados por
todos os consumidores de que na verdade
se eu quisesse eu teria que levar uma
embalagem normal ou então que eu poderia
se integrar o cec o saquinho de frutas e
legumes e colocar minhas castanho lá
dentro e eu aceitei o desafio
quando cheguei em casa meus filhos
atacaram aquele pacote de nozes ele
arrebentou e caíram todas as frutas no
chão estava eu lá com a minha comida no
chão e com um saquinho rasgado na minha
mão
ora será que a lógica de granel
não tem a ver também com a gente deixar
de impactar com embalagens descartáveis
ela aplicada dessa forma não faz tanto
sentido
acontece a mesma coisa com refil o refil
é uma idéia maravilhosa e tem sido
bastante utilizado na indústria de
cosméticos e de limpeza
o que acontece é que quando a gente
escolhe o material para o prefil que não
têm esse claridade nenhuma em
contrapartida daquele da embalagem
original que é mais parrudo e que também
é mais caro
a lógica também não faz sentido então
vocês devem estar sentados pensando bom
essa fala não é pra mim eu já não uso
mais canudo eu já pedalou na ciclofaixa
e leve uma garrafinha sacola
eu tomava banhos curtos apaga a luz o ar
condicionado
até comprei uma escova de bambu
recentemente tudo bem tá cheio de
verdades absolutas né
essa fala é pra vocês essa fala pra mim
cada dia a cada momento que a gente opta
por consumir alguma coisa a gente tem um
voto pra fazer a gente precisa repensar
isso quando a gente consome alguma coisa
a gente consome uma embalagem de um
produto
a gente precisa entender essa lógica mas
como todo mundo sempre fala que a minha
conversa é uma conversa chata e um papo
bem baixo astral e que saiba as
conversas comigo super incomodado eu
achei melhor ou trazer algumas dicas pra
vocês e algumas provocações quem sabe eu
consiga ajudar recusem a cinco fontes
principais de embalagens de uso único
sacolas garrafinhas copos descartáveis
dos canudos e as embalagens para viagem
é um fato os resíduos menores de sete
centímetros não tem a mínima
probabilidade de serem reciclados quando
colocados nos sistemas de coleta e
triagem
a gente sabe bem onde eles vão parar né
informe se existem diferentes tipos de
material existem aplicações boas para
alguns usos e algumas que não são boas
é importante entender que quando a gente
fala de plásticos por exemplo existem
diversos tipos de plástico diferente que
têm comportamentos diferentes
então é quase como se a gente for
comparar um elefante com peixe que os
dois são vertebrados mas que ele tem
todas as características diferentes que
a gente pode imaginar
informa se visitem uma cooperativa de
catadores do bairro de vocês vocês não
têm idéia do que eles podem aprender com
a vida como essa eu estou lá quase toda
semana ea inacreditável conhecimento que
eles têm ea possibilidade que eles têm
de ensinar a gente de diversas formas
não só sobre materiais mais sobrevida
enfim sobre diversas perspectivas
perguntem para eles você lava ou não seu
material com o material eles estão
aceitando ou não que você faz com aquilo
que está parado na sua gaveta enfim com
os eletrônicos etc vão na cooperativa
vão perguntar lá vocês vão se
surpreender lá vem - suas roupas
essas fibras que estão soltas por aí tem
muita responsabilidade da nossa lavagem
então se vocês forem lá vá lavar com
baixa temperatura
a intensidade na hora de comprar algo
novo pensa bem na origem daquele tecido
que vai acontecer com ele depois e aí
porque estão mais animados nem falo
pontos agora eu vou mudar minha vida eu
lanço um desafio
recentemente o fotógrafo americano fez
esse ensaio com algumas pessoas que
passaram sete dias sem jogar fora os
seus resíduos
é bem interessante um pouco assustador
então eu convido vocês estiverem muito
animados a fazer isso se quiserem
compartilhar comigo depois acho que vai
ser bastante interessante entender o
impacto do consumo que a gente anda
consumindo né é um papelzinho de bala
enfim o mexê dorzinha de café foi no
bolso leva pra casa
recentemente eu tive o privilégio de
conhecer esse senhor o elemec dona que
eu já conheci através dos livros que ele
escreve é um arquiteto norte-americano
que fala sobre esse conceito do berço ao
berço a gente chama em português na
época do treino ele trouxe esse conceito
como base do que a gente chama de uma
economia circular e uma das coisas que
ele me provocou na fala pessoal e tocou
dentro do meu coração foi o que a gente
precisa transformar o nosso olhar para
um olhar de abundância como a gente pára
de falar que a gente quer fazer menos
impacto negativo e começa a falar que a
gente quer fazer mais impacto positivo é
muito sutil é uma mudança de mentalidade
é um exemplo que ele traz é que as
nossas metas
tinham que ser que a gente quer ser 100%
fabuloso e não 0 1% ruim
el é simples mas eu acho que faz
bastante sentido
e acho que naquela expedição do pacífico
o que mais prezava a minha liberdade
eu fui pra lá porque eu sou de ir porque
eu gostava daquela oportunidade de estar
me aventurando num veleiro no oceano e
eu tinha muito medo de perder minha
liberdade
hoje em dia eu tenho outros desafios
talvez muito mais complexo do que para o
oceano mas a verdade é que eu tô bem
ponderada com enorme senso de
responsabilidade e liberdade sim que eu
tenho de escolher a maneira com que eu
me relaciono com que o consumo e com os
resíduos que eu gero essa é uma escolha
que ninguém faz por mim
o que eu faço por todos nós obrigado
[Aplausos]